I was actually walking by one day I look
over and I see ping pong balls in the
air I said wow tables sometimes you come
out of work and there you have the
tables then like your buddies they're
waiting for you to come and get the
spits out I take the bus to the Train
they didn't train to another train just
to get here Brian part has a nice New
York type of atmosphere all walks of
life and all the ping pong players come
from all over the world playing at this
Park and it's funny because this used to
be the place called the drug addict
she's become to hang out at one point
like maybe 20 years ago this was like a
no-go zone I know it's completely
changed and completely changed in a
really great way behind each individual
there's a story as I got to know these
people it was fascinating for me to find
out what they went through and
everything led to this place and he made
me feel like I'm not the only one you
know I discovered 10 Kong's
when I was about 11 12 years old I lived
in a foster home and I was the youngest
out of six foster children in the home
and they had a ping-pong table in the
basement and my older foster brothers
did not want me to play in life foster
mother said you got to let him play and
that's how I learned how to play the
game it was strictly under duress I
became a good player
why you got me just play for the
interesting characters to come to Bryant
Park maybe Darren you might be the
funniest guy in the park hyo is that
something clever to say Darren's a real
open guy nap and joke and everybody
always comes and feeds everybody always
goes to jacks by a bunch of photos and
stuff oh and then we got Coney it's like
that Chinese guy who's always here with
the shirt off because he says his hot
well we have Tyrone which we call him
crazy sometimes he brings a wood paddle
just a piece of wood though I like to
say when I'm playing really hard I'm
tough to beat with my block of wood
Wally green as far as I know he's a
professional table tennis player when
you think you're good you'll look at
someone like Wally and realize you have
a far way to go there's another
character this his name is Sir Joey's I
don't know how old he is but he's got to
be past seventy Sergio is a real attack
player but if you give him a high ball
he was smashing and smashing his massive
there's a gentleman by the name of
Gregory Gregory is the rock of the [ __ ]
he's always there you can trust him to
be here he's homeless but he's not he's
not your average homeless man he's kind
of like a box you don't really know it
but you cut out the boss the tables
[Music]
I've been homeless almost two years now
it's not the first time the last time I
was homeless is good I was using drugs
this time it's cause I lost a job and
Here I am of Industry it's hard for me
to find work it's a whole bunch of
things I talked about it's consequence
of my own actions you know years the
drug abuse and shoddy work history and a
really big factor now is my age I'll be
60 in January I'm up against it but I
still have faith that some kind of break
I don't even want more break somewhere
that's got to be ready for it's funny
man in taste I always think of myself as
a good person but I've been I've been to
the prison system I've been there three
times a lot of it had to do with drug
use me smoking crack cocaine if you're
young you start getting in trouble you
don't have money to fight the system
you're going to jail I went to jail I
went to jail a couple of times I said
never again and now I might be a little
bit older but I don't get in trouble do
anything wrong I never was a thief or I
just never was a really bad person I got
back to being wrong supposed to be I'm
not ashamed of it it is what it is but
I've grown I don't stay stagnating and
being a negative person around
negativity there's a saying in 12-step
programs if it says if you change your
thinking you will change your behavior
I've changed the way I think so
therefore I change throughout the age I
love that same tune you'll notice if you
come here often like from about 4
o'clock the regular crew starts it
everyone wonders then you come off their
jobs or they come off doing whatever
they've got to do getting ready for 7
o'clock the regular guys we call
ourselves after 7 guys after 7 the pros
come in
[Music]
so the morning it's like a little we're
like playful on Kitty something that
night it's like where you know things
get a little rugged and they start
playing hardcore at nighttime it's the
ones who had to own paddles that are
hardcore about the game that come here
and play after 7:00 p.m. that's when
things get interesting that's when the
hustling starts and that's when winner
stays on the table we play doubles on
one table and singles on the other and
on a singles table with when it stays on
and you play and play and play - you
can't potato more fun
[Music]
I'm kind of I'm kind of an undercover
guy and because I do play pro tour for
USA and a lot of times I don't want to
tell anybody it's usually the other guys
thing
so currently I represent the u.s. in Pro
Tour competition I play all over the
world and I want to promote this sport
three weeks ago I returned from North
Korea I thought it would be a good
opportunity to go to a totally different
country which is hostile to Americans
and then say hey look I'm American I
play the same sport you play and I'm a
cool-ass [ __ ]
and you're gonna like me I used to be
into a lot of crazy stuff I grew up in
Marlborough projects in Brooklyn at 13 I
own six guns six not one not two I own
six my life took a turn at 19 years old
I met a guy through going to this
ping-pong club at the time I didn't
really have any money and the guy was
like hey you know I'll pay you $20 if
you can play with me just be my
consistent partner so I said twenty
bucks it's a hustle I'll make that money
so I played with this guy for like I
don't know like six months and then we
started becoming friends and then uh
this guy sent me the Germany flight paid
I stayed in this school where all the
young best athletes live and I learned
table tennis and then from that was the
changing point in my life that's what
took me out of the whole gangster thing
if it wasn't for this sport and that guy
I would be the debtor and gel-like all
the way I don't have any friend that I
can say oh this did it this is my friend
I grew up with all my friends are dead
or in jail so all my new friends are
ping pong friends and anything I've done
related to ping pong but most people
don't know that I'm responsible or my
company is responsible for these tables
it makes me feel amazing I mean the fact
that people are playing every day people
are loving it is tournaments so the
whole point of bringing it here wasn't
in vain
it's seven o'clock it's raining pouring
what the tables are all wet and the
ground is all red and we are still here
in hopes our will have economy what's
unique about how tour ping-pong is you
battle your opponent and you battle the
wind if you don't wanna play with the
wind then you're pretty much in trouble
because the ball can drop short you can
hit the ball softly you can fly out
the dog the water drain woman wipe the
tables off play ping-pong love this
gonna rain again
[Music]
people will play in the snow people come
out here and they will play when it says
32 degrees or lower and the ball is
shattering when it hits the net well one
thing about to meet the mental net
affects the game to the net is metal so
usually then that's not too forgiving if
you hit it right on the net it's gonna
bounce weirdly you have to clear the net
instead of rushing the net in front a
hopeful point to go on the other side
you don't get no cheap shots off that
metal net with all these added elements
like the dust when coldness heat it adds
kind of toughness to your game like you
have to anticipate much more before even
things happen play up the same level
here play of the same level there Brian
Park definitely has an advantage but I
think it's fun it's like playing
Wimbledon it's a different experience
[Music]
the people that come here are it's a
community now you know you don't know
what a person has in New York City they
can look like something and be a
billionaire what makes these tables
unique is that they don't ask for any
money at all and without that price you
get a lot of different kinds of people
because there's no there's no obligation
to pay you're just there with everybody
else you know you have the guns working
upstairs making six figures you have the
guy here's the bike messenger making one
figure this guy gets a face on face
meeting where this guy's making six
figures so you meet people who can help
you in your future I found a job and I
find opportunity in my life you know
have a place to stay if I'm Iran and I
have my dignity
the park is stable the park is here it's
not going anywhere
I know I haven't seen getting in a while
since he went to school okay it's live
obviously here I guess and uh where does
he saw up at when I first see him right
here in Bryant Park I got a job I'm a
maintenance guy I work a Wednesday to
Sunday someone in two days I never get
this cute ornament on this
[Applause]
that thing I love about Gideon is Gideon
is uh for young man he's grounded very
well I feel good being around him you
know always makes me feel better
specially I was going through some tough
times and he helped me get to a lot of
tough times I don't even go out of his
way to check on me see if I was doing
okay just really happy to see the guy
you know he's a instrumental in keeping
me an angel in my life helped you know
for a young man you know
everything that I've got now in New
Yorker like all the success I've had
like somehow all the people I've met it
comes from the tables of it right over
there like whenever I come out here I
feel like I'm just a regular guy you
know I'm not a soldier I'm just the guy
that's coming I get to play paintball
and photography we don't say I'm here
I'm still alive and I'm somebody it's a
respite from the drama you you come here
you play ping pong and everything else
doesn't matter for the collage that
you're here I wouldn't know where I
would go if I join the daytime I didn't
come here I don't know where to go I see
that it give people is a way you found
your heaven you know and I found my
heaven dead
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]